sacrebleu will not catch me friends it
master of parkour oh hello this new
movie brick mansions tells a story of a
whatever I don't care what's important
is it it's a remake of the French film
district their team which was simply a
vehicle for parkour actions sold this is
what motion pictures were meant to
portray motion I mean look at Buster
Keaton look at Bruce Lee what I want to
know is why hasn't David Bell creator of
parkour and co-star and brick mansions
become a star as big as Bruce Lee the
park or sequence in casino royale was
great but explain to me why parkour
cinema isn't its own genre like martial
arts cinema I blame the French those
smug snooty cinephiles think they're
above park war they should be more like
the Hong Kong filmmaking community which
recognized the sheer beauty of martial
arts cinema and built that kinetis asst
into films about gun
off of cooking and sex tell me you don't
wish the next gianluca dark film had the
stars vaulting over fences running up
walls as they discuss their on we think
about how great that was encroaching
tiger I mean sure the actors would have
been cut way down and their gold wha
cigarettes to pull off those sick moves
but international box office receipts
explode is the issue that parkour is to
urban and modern do we have to wait
hundreds of years for the form to become
as venerated as kung fu I refuse to
accept that I want to see people
clambering around on rooftops in every
single francophone film now if you
recorded yourself doing cool parkour
moves post a link in the comments and
subscribe to the wired channel what
movie do you think would be most
improved by adding parkour for me it's
between august osage county and my
dinner with andre let me know your pics
in the comments